- On this episode we got shut down.
(hip hop music)
♫ You ask questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is the #AskGaryVee Show ♫
- Alright, I'll go into selfie
mode until she gets here.
What up Animal, what up Tucker.
Good to see you Tom, looks
like, oh there's India.
Let's see, let's track India.
Let's track India's
walk to doing the show,
there she is in the mix in
New York City, there she is.
(laughter)
- [Gary] Here she comes, there she is.
Hi India.
- Hi.
- [Gary] You're on Facebook Live.
- Yay.
- How you doing?
- Good.
- You ready to go?
- Yeah.
- This is Rockefeller Center, right?
(laughter)
- This is actually really cool.
- It's so pretty though.
- Cool, ready?
- [DRock] Uh, yes.
- Do you want to do anything
kind of like cool or?
- [DRock] No.
- Wow. Nice shoes, very white.
- [DRock] Thank you.
169?
- [India] 169.
- Hey everybody, this
is Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 169 of
the #AskGaryVee Show.
This really works out nicely,
we are at Rockefeller Center,
it's pretty DRock, did
you show the skating rink?
- [DRock] Nope.
- It's really nice, really
nice and it feels very festive
this time of year, good to be here.
A beautiful Friday morning in New York.
I don't know, I can't
debate global warming,
because I'm just not
educated in any shape or
form in the issue but man
it's nice to be nice and
warm in December and not wear a coat.
And I'm excited huge Jets Giants game.
I actually decided in
the shower this morning
that I don't want to
predict it, I really don't.
I just don't have that feel anymore.
I'm sorry, I know so many
people want the prediction.
I will make one prediction,
Odell Beckham may literally
break all time NFL records,
no Revis, no Markus Williams,
we're on our third corner,
it's gonna get ugly out there.
I see the Giants putting
up a lot of passing yards.
I'm very concerned India,
very concerned.
Get in here. Are you scared?
Do you feel like the cop
is going to arrest you?
- No, I don't want to
mess up DRock's shot.
- Oh, DRock's shot, got it.
It's good to see you India.
- It's good to see you too.
- Alright, let's do this.
- [Voiceover] Helena asks,
"Any advice for people
"working 7 pm to 2 am doing
what they love, but aren't
"sure how to monetize it, such as a blog?"
- Helena?
- Yeah.
- You know Helena I think, you
know, I think it's dangerous
not to have a concept of
how you're gonna monetize
if you want money
as a KPI meaning, I need
everybody understand, there's a difference
between strategy and patience.
You need to be patient to
execute your strategy but you
need a strategy, and by the
way, strategy is very easy.
If you're building a personal
brand or you're talking
about coffee or things
of that nature, whatever
you're doing there's
a lot of ways to sell.
You sell as being a personality,
you show up at events
to get paid for that, you
make a book and you sell that,
you create a product, like a
coffee maker and you sell that.
There's not a lot of different
ways to monetize and make
money, you make it through
advertising, you make it
through appearance fees, you
make it through selling stuff.
It's quite basic so I've saved
you time on your strategy,
that's how you're gonna monetize.
You're either gonna
syphon the leverage into
a product, a service or your time.
That's it, that's your strategy.
I've told you, you now know
how you're gonna do it.
Now, what you really need to
worry about is does anybody
give a crap about what you're
doing between seven and two.
You can't just talk about
loving knitting or loving
sneakers but nobody
thinks you're good at it.
You know there's a little
bit of a metatocracy in this.
The market has to care, and if the
market doesn't care, you lose.
- [Voiceover] Daniel asks,
"I'm starting a fatherhood
blog, how would you market it?"
- I would go to Instagram
and search every hashtag
that you can think of
around fatherhood, starting
with fatherhood, Stunwin,
let's put you to work.
Can you quickly check how many people have
used the fatherhood hashtag on Instagram.
I would go to Twitter search
and I'd go to Instagram search
and I would search the fatherhood hashtag.
I would then look at
the content and I would
engage with it, I would do that under the
the name of your blog, not as Rick.
- 464,000 of them.
- 464,000, so there's
464,000 pieces of content
on Instagram that you can engage with in a
jab way under an account you
create for the fatherhood
blog, you go look at the
piece of content, you look
at what the dad or the
mom of the dad and the kid
wrote and you engage with
it, like "that's cute".
Like I would go look at one, I'd see a dad
holding a Patriots, a little Patriot baby,
because it has a Patriot bib and I would
jump in and be like boo
Patriots, you suck, but cute kid.
Be real, jab, don't be
like come to my blog,
it's really good, you
want to learn more about
fatherhood come to my, no that's spam.
Engage in the community,
work 15 hours a day,
grind, grind, grind,
grind, grind, that is the
easiest and hardest way to do it.
The other thing you can
do is go and map the
25-50 important fatherhood
blogs and platforms
and ask to guest blog and
then you're syphoning that
audience, now you have to write
a good blog because nobody
will come over if you stink and
that would be another thing.
I'd also scrap up a couple
bucks, I would spend $20-50
a week, instead of buying a
shake or taking an Uber or
going to see Star Wars, take
that $20-50 and buy Facebook
ads against dads that show
interest about being a dad.
There's a million things that you can do.
India.
- A little angry, isn't that?
- I'm a little angry,
I'm excited that was fun.
That was like, I've been
talking about Crush It! since
2009 let's get our shit together people.
That's what that was.
- Alright, from Eric.
- Eric.
- [Voiceover] Eric wants
to know, "What makes a
"company more investable,
millions of active users
"consuming free content or
millions in actual profit?"
- Millions in actual profit.
- Next question, alright.
(laughter)
- I haven't done an answer
where I didn't expand on it
in a long time, I've picked
this moment to do that.
- From Carter.
- [Voiceover] Carter asks,
"How do you prepare for a
"big meeting or anything where you're
"required to have a strong performance?"
- Carter, I prepare for a big
meeting by living my life.
Meaning, I am always
prepared for a big meeting
thus I never prepare for a big meeting.
Meaning, when you're great at something or
very good at something you don't need any
prep time because you're always prepping.
Right, and so that's the
punch line of me in a
professional meeting standpoint.
The years of experience,
the bravado, the results,
the cadence, the natural skills,
the two things that matter,
practice and natural
talent have been there so
I don't prepare for a big meeting.
It's not like I get pumped
up, I don't put in like
Lil Wayne and be like alright,
we're gonna go get it.
There's none of that, there's
no looking in the mirror
and being like okay, we're
gonna win this pitch.
There's none of that bullshit.
I put in the work everyday,
365 to be ready for
that and I think anybody
that's very good at
something is always doing that.
You know, you don't just wake up and
decide you're gonna be good at something.
You're always preparing.
If you're preparing in a
tactic way you're unprepared.
Yeah.
- Wow.
- You like that right, that
was some deep ass shit, right?
- That was really good, yeah.
- Yeah, I mean like, how
am I gonna prepare to cook
a great meal for these homies right now?
The answer is, I'm not.
There's no reading a blog
post or watching Youtube video
or calling a chef friend,
like I'm gonna f** it up.
I haven't done anything
for 40 years that preps
me to cook a good meal to you.
That was some high level shit.
- That was high level shit.
- Boy I have so much
more energy when there's
other human beings around.
Like literally, I'm feeling,
like this dude right here
this big man is giving me energy.
- This is from Samantha,
do you have headphones?
- Samantha, I gotta listen, right?
I have had headphones.
- Or do you want to just listen?
- No, no I got headphones. Bam.
- Nice.
- Right in your face India.
- What the hell?
- I'm very competitive right now.
Here, plug this in.
- [Officer] Excuse me guys,
what are you doing here?
- [Stunwin] Uh, we're shooting.
- You can't.
- This is a public place.
- No, this is public space, this is
private space open to the public.
- Okay, no worries, we'll just end it.
Alright guys, you heard the man.
We have to listen, you
keep asking questions
I'll keep answering them.
We got shut down.
- Great to meet you,
it is, yeah absolutely.
(laughter)
- Thank you so much, keep
doing what you do man.
Thank you, happy
holidays, Merry Christmas.
- Take care.
- Yup, that happened.
- People don't do that,
it's like a lot of people.
Someone was like oh I
had a meeting right by
Time Warner and I saw
you there and I was like
I guess people are like around.
- People don't want to
bother us sometimes.
- Oh yeah, I can't imagine going up to a
famous person like that.
- Oh, when I see Jets
players I get so hung up
but I would never bother them.
- Just til you stop doing that.
- [Gary] Yes DRock.
(hip hop music)